[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero
Andrés Manuel López Obrador cumplió este
primero de diciembre su cuarto
aniversario como presidente de México
amlo llegó al poder con una fuerte
Promesa de cambio luego de décadas en la
oposición y fuertes críticas al
establecimiento político mexicano y
cuatro años después mantiene un 65% de
aprobación entre el electorado a pesar
de las críticas de sus opositores que
señalan que en este periodo ha habido
muy pocos cambios a pesar de las
promesas de una cuarta transformación
política en México en Francia 24
queremos repasar la trayectoria de este
político los inicios de amlo en la
carrera política están Precisamente en
uno de los partidos opositores a su
presidencia el partido revolucionario
institucional o pri durante la década de
1980 este escritor ocupó varios cargos
públicos en el Estado de Tabasco su
región natal
que en 1988 salió del partido junto a la
corriente más progresista para crear el
frente democrático nacional a partir de
la década de los 90 este partido pasó a
llamarse partido de la Revolución
democrática o PRD habló decidió optar a
la gobernación de Tabasco en 1994 y
perdió pero ganó relevancia nacional por
sus denuncias de fraude contra el
prerrey en esa elección López Obrador
inició así una caravana por la
democracia por todo el país que lo llevó
a reunir a decenas de miles de personas
en Ciudad de México en 1995 que
protestaban contra la corrupción del
Perri
este archivo es una prueba contundente
de la ilegalidad de las elecciones de
Tabasco del 20 de noviembre de 1994 tras
estas marchas amlo se convirtió en el
presidente del PRD y en uno de sus
líderes más importantes junto a
Cuauhtémoc cá
una posición que le permitió ganar las
elecciones a la gobernatura del Distrito
Federal de México en el año 2000 su
gobierno Durante los primeros años del
siglo en la capital fue altamente
popular entre la población gracias a un
programa de ayudas públicas extenso un
crecimiento sostenido de la economía y
una reducción de la criminalidad
sin embargo amlo sufrió en 2005 un
proceso de desafuero por prevaricación
que lo sacó del alcaldía de la capital
de forma prematura López Obrador ya era
para ese tiempo la mayor figura de
oposición al entonces presidente Vicente
Fox y afirmó que esta condena era una
estrategia del gobierno central para que
no pudiera presentarse a las elecciones
presidenciales del año 2006 el primer
paso
para la consumación
de un hecho A todas luces
Injusto
autoritario y antidemocrático mucha
gente pensaba de buena fe
que no se iban a atrever a consumar la
can hallada del desafuero Finalmente
amlo sí pudo concurrir a esas comicios y
quedó en segunda posición a menos de
250.000 votos de su máximo rival el
expresidente Felipe Calderón las
votaciones tuvieron una gran polémica y
López Obrador llegó a acusar a Calderón
de fraude electoral y comenzó a
organizar masivas movilizaciones en su
contra Aunque Se realizaron recuentos
parciales en algunos centros electorales
durante las siguientes semanas al final
el líder del pan tomó posesión
sí les permitimos que se impongan
mediante el fraude
va a ser
una regresión López Obrador se fue
consolidando como el principal líder de
la oposición a los dos partidos más
importantes de México el pri Y el pan y
lideró protestas contra medidas
gubernamentales como la guerra contra el
narcotráfico iniciada en 2006 amlo se
presentó de nuevo a las elecciones en
2012 y a pesar de su alta popularidad
volvió a perder Los comicios con el
candidato del Pri Enrique Peña Nieto
esto supuso que amlo volviera a estar
otros seis años en la oposición un
período en el que el actual mandatario
se alejó del PRD y comenzó a formar su
propia coalición llamada morena Sin
embargo a la tercera fue la vencida y en
2018 ante el hartazgo político
generalizado amlo logró una victoria
histórica con más del 53% de los votos
pero hoy
no solo inicia un nuevo gobierno
hoy comienza
un cambio de régimen político López
Obrador llegó al poder con tres
políticas como ejes fundamentales la
primera de ellas era el combate a la
corrupción además quería crear un estado
de bienestar y pacificar todo el país
unas cuestiones que no siempre se han
cumplido el gobierno de López Obrador ha
tenido un marcado carácter social en
comparación con los anteriores Y ha
sabido mantener una estabilidad en la
economía a pesar de la situación
internacional pero se ha enfrentado a
numerosas polémicas como su gestión en
la pandemia de Kobe 19 amlo se mostró
contrario al uso de tapabocas y los
confinamientos en la peor fase de esta
pandemia y sobre todo en torno a la
seguridad ya que la política de afrontar
la violencia del narcotráfico terminando
con la guerra iniciada por sus
predecesores no ha bajado el nivel de
asesinatos ni de violencia que azota a
México cuestiones como la resolución de
casos tan emblemáticos como la
desaparición de 43 estudiantes en
Ayotzinapa siguen además también en el
aire a pesar de haberse creado una
comisión de la verdad además otras
controversias como las consecuencias
ambientales de infraestructuras como el
tren Maya o el enfrentamiento con grupos
feministas
picado a su gobierno polémicas que
aunque han afectado algo a su imagen no
han golpeado de lleno a su gobierno su
popularidad sigue siendo muy alta y de
cara al año que viene se espera que sea
el mismo quien designe al futuro
candidato de morena además de participar
activamente en la campaña algo que hace
pensar a muchos que su poder seguirá una
vez terminen estos seis años con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]